I don't believe in the concept of
strengths and weaknesses everything has
context
um I believe we have attributes we have
characteristics that we have to know and
in some contexts those attributes are
strength and sometimes their weaknesses
so I'll give you the example that I like
to use all the time because it's funny
is I am chronically disorganized I'm
very disorganized right you are terribly
yeah
um uh and uh
um and I've always thought of this as a
weakness I mean what are your weaknesses
I'm disorganized right yeah so I was at
a networking event many years ago
in the early days of my career and I met
a guy and he was like Simon you're
fantastic would love to work with you
here's my card and if I was organized
I'd be texting from the cab on the way
home or emailing the next day when I get
to work you know of course but I'm
disorganized I lost the business card
almost immediately right uh two weeks
later I found the business card at the
bottom of a briefcase
and so I emailed him I said I don't know
if you remember me we met two weeks ago
you know I'd love to reconnect and he
wanted to work with me more because he
thought I was busy
he thought there was such high demand
for him yes that's why it took so long
right that's why it took so long so it
was being disorganized to strength
through a weakness the answer is it
depends in that context it was actually
a strength in different contexts when
somebody says I need you to get this
done by this time it can be a liability
so what stacking the deck means is
putting yourself in situations where
your attributes are more likely to
reveal themselves as strengths and try
and avoid situations where your
attributes are more likely to pull you
back right so stacking the deck is not
about cheating it's about it's about
making sure that you're in the right
place that make you strong and avoiding
the places that make you weak you know
so for example if you're bad at math
don't do jobs that require lots of math
right right
yes it's it's it's it's I know it sounds
trite but yeah it's true it's sometimes
that silly you know
um like I love working
with others I love working on teams
right and so when a project comes up I
always make sure that I have a group
that I can work with because I know I'll
do better work if I work by myself it's
more stressful and the work is a lower
standard and so I know that about me I
know that I have a I I like working with
people so I stack the deck I try very
hard to work at least with one other
person or to work on on a team to
complete a project right right as
opposed to leave this to me I'll get
this done by myself some people that is
their strength to work by themselves not
me right so again
I try and stack the deck by working with
people as often as possible when I have
difficult things to do